[Music]
hello good afternoon
my name is tarek ali
and i'm going to talk about the
situation in afghanistan and the war
that came to an end last august
the first thing to understand is that
it's it's important to remember
that prior to the nato
invasion occupation of afghanistan
in 2001
afghanistan had been occupied by the
soviet union
the the name of russia
before the collapse of communism
for
10 years
this 10-year occupation had begun in
1979
uh december the last week of december
1979 and carried on till december 1989
and
the aim of the russians
was to
keep the
left-wing government
in afghanistan in power as long as
possible
to get rid of the more unruly elements
and
they thought the only way to do it was
to have troops on the ground
so they could control the situation
better
at the same time we now know because all
these facts have come into the public
domain
the united states
drew
the russians into afghanistan through a
series of provocations
and convinced them
that they had to intervene to save their
government
years later
as
big brzezinski
president carter's
national security advisor
went to the pakistan afghanistan border
and
dispatched sent off
with friendly
exclamations
the
jihadi groups
mainly far-right religious groups to go
and fight the
russians and he said to them
long live the jihad
so the trouble in afghanistan
began in 1978 with the left-wing coup
d'etat
sustained by the russians from 79
onwards game that first phase game to an
end in 89 with the russian withdrawal
for a few years
the different groups who had fought
against the russians now fought against
each other
the
destruction that was wrought on kabul
was basically the result of
intra-faction fighting with guns and
weaponry supplied by both in different
times the russians in the united states
and they fought each other to a
standstill
and it was at this stage
that the afghan
the
young children or students of afghan
refugees
and many refugees in pakistan were
dispatched to afghanistan
to take over the word taliban means
student that was the appellation they
were given
but the whole operation could not have
been possible without the pakistani
military the inter-services intelligence
playing a key role and given lots and
lots of
dosh by the united states to go and do
this
so the taliban was propelled
into
power
by the
in the
mid to late 90s
and stayed there till 2001.
the taliban government was of course a
religious
government it had been created by
with that particular rain
and
there was mayhem in the country for some
time till a certain degree one has to
acknowledge of stability
was
imposed on the country
and it seemed that at long last possibly
afghanistan would be able to function
without any war
but this was a vain hope
because the afghan government gave
refuge to al-qaeda the group which it
once fought or the leaders of the group
had once fought with the united states
on the side of the united states in
afghanistan
and now moved
into opposition they felt the americans
had let them down they'd stop supplies
of money and weaponry etc etc they felt
they'd been used and they set up a small
organization of terrorists that's the
only word
whose aim was to blow up u.s embassies
attack u.s
warships
and buildings and they did this they
they blew up attacked the u.s embassy in
kenya they attacked a u.s ship in the
waters surrounding the yemen
and their aim always had been to target
big buildings in the united states
itself
and they did this with the events of 9
11
when many of you will recall
the pentagon was attacked
and uh
the twin towers were destroyed uh those
dramatic scenes which i think even if
you were very young you probably
remember
until this day you know 20 years ago two
decades ago
the attacks were launched
by al-qaeda
they admitted them
they celebrated them
in their hideouts in in kabul
and the united states then decided to
wage war to capture the al-qaeda leaders
afghanistan was asked to surrender them
the afghan government its position was
interesting it didn't say no
it said
could we see some evidence that it is
al-qaeda
and the united states
as is the want of great big powers
imperial power said no we can't waste
any time hand them over we're going to
come in and while this
taliban government was making up its
mind
the united states
after a
two-week delay
after 9 11 went and took afghanistan the
advice given by the pakistani military
to the taliban government and its
supporters was
do not resist
do not fight
you will be wiped out if you do
go back to your villages come to
pakistan if you have to
and just stay calm your time will come
again if the occupation is bungled
it was intelligent advice from their
point of view
and uh so the taliban disappeared
or so it seemed many did come to
pakistan
others stayed went back to their
villages
and within a few years
the occupation had begun to go wrong
for the following reasons
e
and this should be understood
no people
whatever the color of their skin
whatever their religion like being
occupied no one likes it it's a natural
thing
so there was opposition
from the beginning but it wasn't clearly
expressed in any shape or form but
within
five years four to five years the
resistance had begun
started by the
taliban and slowly spreading
and this resistance got support
because of the
huge number of bombs that were dropped
on innocents in afghanistan
this was has been acknowledged
now in 2010 some acknowledged it in
2015.
wikileaks
published dossier
outlining all the crimes and horrors
that were being inflicted on the country
ordinary people dying in indiscriminate
drone attacks
weddings were people in that region to
celebrate fire guns
taught
to be armed groups and bombed from the
skies and
you know torture
uh
restarted in a big way now
um in
by the united states
and so so on
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas